9-1-1 what's the address of the  emergency we have a person drowning  drowning where what's the address  [Music]  water rescue  drive we have a nine-year-old that fell  in the water and they're not able to get  out telling one is until the engine five  medicate Robert 21 truck six Auto Rescue  at 20 40.  [Laughter]  here over here  foreign  rescue kits are about 15 feet into the  middle  okay  thank you  [Applause]  foreign  right there  behind you behind you  foreign  let's go  come on  ready come on one two three up one keep  going  and I thought my son was not gonna be  here to see Thanksgiving  somebody was out there to call 9-1-1  and start and I want to thank the little  boy and his parents out there as well  and I want to thank all the people who  rescued him out there